- Le socle où se trouvait
la statue de John A. Macdonald,
au centre-ville de Montréal,
pourrait bien demeurididide
après tout.
(cohue)
Durant une manifestation
contre le racietetet
la brutalité policière
en 2020, elle avait été
déboulonnée, puis décapitée.
(cohue)
Elle a ensuité été entreposée.
Un comité formé par la Ville
de Montréal devait déterminer
soenenenir.
DINU BUMBARU, comité évaluation,
monument, John A. Macdonald
- La question centrale
esesest : qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec une statue que
des personnes un petit peu
impatientes ont jetée à terre
comme ça?
- Ce comité, dans un avis
préliminaire publié aujourd'hui,
exclut la possibilité
de remettre la statue
de John A Macdonallalalalace
telle qu'elle était.
Il recommande de laisser
la structure en place et
de lui donner une nouvelle
signification.
- Est-ce que ce monument
pourrait être associé à des...
des commémorations, par exemple,
de la Journée nationale
de réconciliation?
ANDRÉ DUDEMAINE, comité,  éval.,
monument, sir John A. Macdonald
- On le voit comme celui
qui a poursuivi, de sa haine,
Louis Riela a a a a amené
à la potence. C'est quelqu'un
qui a été le père de l'exclusion
des Autochtones.
- Les monuments à l'effigie
du premier premier ministre
du Canada ont provoqué la
controverse partout au pays.
La Ville de Montréal n'est pas
prête à faire connaître
ses intentions.
ERICKA ALNEUS, resp. culture et
patrimoine au comité exécutif
- On accueille toutes
les recommandations qui ont été
faites, puis on sisisisisi
entendre les Montréalais
à ce sujet.
(rires)
- Je suis... euh... mitigé.
- Si on veut avancer, il faut
comprendre d'où on vient.
- Les citoyens de Montréal
auront l'occasion de
se prononcer sur l'avenir
du monument à l'occasion
d'une séance d'étude publique
tenue par la Ville dans
deux semaines. Après quoi,
le comité formulera
ses recommandations finales.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Montr